if you've wondered why data catalogues
might be important if you consider for
those of us who have been in software
engineering for a long time yeah it
seems like back in the old days we used
to have a single source to source of
truth which was basically contained in a
monolith database think Oracle or db2 or
Informix and this database used to be
the core of our entire information
storage ability basically it was the
source of truth for our entire
organization it was also one of the
largest sources of our licensing fees as
well but today particularly thanks to
the exploding adoption of micro services
we have databases for every purpose for
analytics for document storage or even
for feature storage if you're doing ml
in some cases some databases are
relational summer columnar some are
denormalized some are aggregated some
are meta stores or materialized views on
top of other data data or databases as
well so with this simultaneous
fragmentation and proliferation of data
the data itself is spread across smaller
silos all over the organization meaning
teams face increasing challenges in
making efficient use of the data that
they have hence
data discovery becomes a key issue that
many scaling data and business teams
face so here today to talk about data
discovery challenges and how a data data
data catalog can solve this problem is
mark Grover so as I mentioned mark as
the co-creator of amundsen which is a
data catalog that's been open sourced at
lyft where he's also a product manager
and previously Mark has also been a
committed to various open source data
related Apache projects for quite a good
number of years before lyft he was a
software engineer at Cloudera for five
years where they work primarily on spark
streaming so mark welcome to the show I
thank you for having me Pete super
excited
[Music]
let me just fix that there we go sorry
about that mark so one of the things
that you know mark his data console is a
community and so today we have a bunch
of people tuning in live and as an
experiment we decided that we wanted to
make this interactive as interactive as
possible and both hear from friend
listeners regarding their their data
cataloging and a discovery challenges
and also take questions from the
audience a little bit more in real time
than we did last time where last time
you went till the end of the show so I
just wanted to encourage the attendees
up there to stay active in the chat
we're gonna be asking you some poll like
questions that you can just sound off on
the chat and we'll aggregate responses
to the best of our ability and we're
also going to take as many questions
that you have for mark as well which
potentially can even shape the
conversation so please stay active in
the chat and we'll do our best to make
use of that signal so mark just to kick
things off I wanted to ask you like why
is data discovery a big deal you've
thought about this problem a lot you've
seen lots of different modern
organizations why does this problem
exist and and what attracted you to it
yeah what I found out lyft and many
other organizations is that there are
two kinds of growth that leads to some
pain in understanding and finding what
trustworthy data I can use for my work
and so we can start with what the work
looks like so the work can be an
analysis that's done by an analyst or it
could be writing an m/l model that's
done by a data scientist but for that
work regardless of what the downstream
analytical or m/l use case is you have
to find what is the trustworthy source
for data for me to use and like you
alluded to one big reason for this is
that organizations are increasing the
amount of data they are putting in their
various databases in particular the one
that I was super
intent on looking at was the analytical
databases and then even even their even
just like blue one database you would
find that different teams are putting
different kinds of data and you don't
quite know what which one is the right
one for you to use the second one is
that the number of people who are coming
into the organization or leaving the
organization or changing their roles is
also very important right so there
that's the other sort of reason where
you don't have this central one person
or a few people small team where you can
go ask all these questions right so the
main problem is what data can I trust
for my work and once I have found it how
do I understand what each of the fields
and attributes and the statistics and
the shape of the data that I need to
know in order to do a productive job at
my work and that was a problem that I
found was taking 25 and 30 percent of
people's time when they were doing their
work and that was clearly way too much
not productive
well I just want to pause here and send
out a bit of a micro poll to the
audience I'm asking folks to sign off
how many people listening out there
actually have a data discovery problem
if you can just respond in the chat
we will that'll be helpful signal for us
so mark before we we get into more about
the the data catalog I want to salute
you on your choice of name for the
product I grew up in northern Minnesota
and I sort of had a lot of Norwegian and
Scandinavian Scandinavians living around
me and so Roald Amundsen was kind of a
household name because he was a great
Norwegian explorer who was quite a
geographical hacker he was the one who
figured out how to take sled dogs from a
South Pole and growing up we had a pack
of sled dogs in our backyard that we
would would run around the neighborhood
so anyway I just wanted to salute you
for that that little tip of the hat to
some Scandinavians up there and and let
you know that the Scandinavian here
appreciate that thank you yeah the
credit goes to an engineer on the team
baito who came up with the name who was
he Reiser
geographic nerd himself I think the hard
part about the name is that if you
aren't from that part of the world are
super familiar it's super hard to say
super hard to spell super hard to like
do anything with so frozen I get it
well obscure obscure names are on the
focus of many software engineering teams
so well done there so mark like what
what was it that sort of led you to this
problem space because one of the things
that I find that's super interesting are
the origin stories of these projects and
sort of projects that take on a larger
than life component or become sort of a
force of nature like it sounds like
Amundson has I'm wondering like what was
it that dragged you into the space like
how like what's a quick version of that
story yeah I think the quick version
would be spending a lot of time with the
users in this case so I was lucky enough
to spend time and looking and
understanding the workflows off some key
data scientists at lift and also was
lucky enough to see what were some of
the shared problems across the industry
looking at companies like Airbnb and
Facebook and LinkedIn and sort of
figuring out if these these challenges
here are something that's just at left
maybe because of organizational
structure or something specific to lift
or are they broader right and so I would
answer that question in two parts one
was understanding the user pain and
workflow and the second one was an
understanding if this is like something
broader than just lift or something
specific to the organization I was a
part of how many team host would you say
are using amundsen right now yeah so
when we started Amundsen Devon was
obviously close source we had thought of
potentially making an open-source and
later on but the goal was to solve the
problem for the data scientist that left
right and that number grew organically
and so the number of weekly actives for
Amazon is actually you know over five
almost seven hundred weekly actives
every every week and that's within the
company
since then Edmondson is open-source and
there are about 20 organizations outside
of lift that use it the likes of square
ing edmunds.com reddit and so these
organizations are using mostly for data
discovery there's one organization
squirt who's taken Amundsen and we can
talk more about this later in the
conversation too but they've taken
Amundsen and actually used it for a
slightly different use case and they are
using it for security and access
management in one year previous data
Council talks I saw the graph of
Amundsen use at lyft I think it's the
one that's going up and up and up and
then all of a sudden it drops to like
almost zero and then it goes up and up
and up and of course the drop to zero is
Christmas
I think of 2019 or 18mm so perfectly
understandable but like in other in the
most meaningful sense it's really just
about happened to the right what do you
think has gotten the business so excited
about havin s'en left how do people use
it and and how has it made their jobs
infinitely easier yeah I think I think
of Amundsen actually as a marketplace it
started it started off like focusing and
understanding the workflow for data
scientists but really you have signals
that come from the data engineering team
and they they also use the data in
Amundsen for discovering where data sets
they need to do use to do their pipeline
development but also for the data sets
they create it acts as a communication
mechanism between the data engineering
team and the users of this data which is
usually a data scientist or analyst or
operations people and so those are the
main main ways that's used here and left
as to understand what data is
trustworthy through automated signals
and I think that was the key sort of
difference - previously there are some
tools that existed in it in the industry
but they rely a lot on curated metadata
so if I'm the data engineer and Pete's
the data analyst the data engineer is
gonna put use this data set it's like
good for you right and I actually like
put in all the descriptions and and
ownership information it's like a lot of
work that's painful and so what Amundsen
relies on is can I get some of this
information
matically and use that as a proxy for
trust so an example is can I get how
often a data set is queried and use that
to power the search ranking so that even
though I haven't gotten like this
rubber-stamp on every single table right
I still have a good sense of what's most
commonly used in the company and
therefore a good sense of like
trustworthiness that's not to say that
we should take out the human signals
right human signals sometimes are
important and they often very important
but the tool doesn't entirely rely on
human signals yeah I think the point
here is that and one of the things I've
discovered I'm through listening to some
of your other interviews is that search
popularity and sport relevance aren't
always the same thing or data popularity
and data relevance might be more correct
to say how do you distinguish between
those two in the way that you serve as
search results to the Amundsen product
because at its core it's a search
interface for data is that fair yeah
absolutely totally yeah my favorite
example to give about relevance versus
popularity is say you go to google and
you search for Apple right and if Google
shows you an orange as a result then
that's not a relevant result right but
if it showed you the fruit Apple as a
result and that's the role of result but
honestly maybe when you type Apple
you're actually perhaps not searching
for the fruit you're searching for the
computer company right and that's where
a popularity comes in so maybe I matched
two results with Apple the fruit and the
computer company but depending on the
context the team you work in or what you
usually search for I know that perhaps
you're searching for the computer
company right and then you can take this
analogy to the data world and you can
say like okay you search for the rides
table or the the bikes table or
something like that but then when you
when you type in some more information
like weekly rides or something like that
can we use that information in the
context where you sit in the
organization to power search experience
that's related to you
and using existing automated signals to
provide trustworthy information back to
you so we have a question already coming
in a couple questions actually the first
of which is does lyft plan to leave the
Russian taxi market which might be
beyond your purview yeah I'm not sure if
I'm the best person to answer that
question but thank you for all the
questions out there another one that I
think mark you might have more to say
about regarding other commercial
solutions such as Malaysian or calibra
which I wanted to ask you as well
because there's a whole host of
commercial and open source solutions
LinkedIn has data hub there's one from
Netflix I forget was it medic at there
you go so there's a there's a bunch of
options how do you compete or
compare/contrast yourself against those
those things of the teams are history as
well that's a really great question so
we did that analysis when we started
amundsen we continue to do that analysis
periodically I'll share my perspective
maybe it's best to start with the
commercial vendors first and then we can
go to the open source category so the on
space there are a few vendors that were
called out earlier I think there are two
main things that were in our
requirements for a munson that we did
find these vendors me the first one was
that we wanted less human signal on an
ongoing basis in order to power trust
for the experience right and like I said
before there were tools that like
require human to go and put on all this
information but we were for example key
decisions like using the query logs to
parse out who's using it you know
connecting that to the HR database and
figuring out like how far they are from
your famiry HR chain and using that to
power and experience was super important
to us and so that was a one main reason
is like rely
on automated usage and metadata as much
as possible the second reason was that
we realized that once we had this
metadata we would want to use it for
other purposes right so we would want to
send programmatically metadata to this
so for example in lift case we have some
ml pipelines that actually
programmatically tag certain datasets
with certain tags but we also want to
access this data programmatically and
you are seeing this in squares use case
where they're taking the metadata that's
present in amundsen with certain tags on
columns to then like you know these tags
are things like whether it's calm is
personal or PII and then using it to
then determine if this individual who's
requesting access to this data set
should get access to it
right and so that use case is not
possible unless you have programmatic
access to the metadata right and that
was one other requirement that we didn't
see commercial solutions fulfilling and
one of the most fascinating things I
think about
Amonson is is where you get this
real-time obviously you're scraping lots
of different data stores and data
sources across the org I've also heard
that you ingest presto logs in order to
figure out access patterns to determine
which data actually might fit that
popular that popularity query talk to me
a little bit about that yeah the first
version of famine s'en got two kinds of
metadata the first kind was like you
said from the table metadata so think of
it like information schema from your
post for strata based tables in the
columns and the second kind was scraping
the presto logs or database query logs
in order to determine what tables are
highly queried and by whom right so we
have a graph database backing amundsen
which then uses you know nodes and edges
between various things so there are
nodes and for a table and column but
then there are connections between
tables themselves between peoples who
access the table and then the weight of
search is determined by this activity I
do want to point out that as Amundson
has matured we are getting a lot more
metadata so a few other sources of
metadata we have added our
airflow information so you can see which
dag generated this table and sort of
linked the airflow dag to the to the
Amundsen page but then we also have
information around ownership which can
obviously be represented different
places for a different organization but
you have that metadata in the graph
structure and then depending on how your
organization stores that information
you graph that in we now have
information about dashboards so one
problem we saw that is like okay we help
you do new analysis but what about
analysis that has already existed in the
past how do you discover that right so
we recently added functionality for what
we called a monthsand dashboards which
means you can search for previously
existing work through the same
capability instead of using the query
count we use view come and and run count
to determine what may be relevant so
those are examples of metadata that we
have added more recently I'm sure I'm
missing a few but so the this design
decision to use a drop a graph database
that's fascinating to me how did you
arrive at that decision did you try it
seems before you step on a graph
database we made that decision because
we felt that the representation off the
structure here was logically a graph and
mate and the way we wanted to access it
was very very akin to graph queries we
had also seen some prior work here for
example Airbnb has a data portal and
they had chosen to use a graph database
Facebook has an internal product that's
very similar to this and they use a
graph unsurprisingly for facebook
perhaps and so there was some intuition
based on our patterns but also some
validation based on how other companies
with closed source products had had
chosen about their design so based on
this this graph concept I wanted to get
to this a bit more because first of all
it's fascinating to me that you must
model all these relationships in a graph
it makes perfect sense when you think
about it but what about the extra
functionality that it might enable I've
heard you talk before about how when a
user is discovering which data set they
might or which data element they might
want to use that lifts not only can they
see sort of the popularity of that
column some statistics on that column
which systems or DAGs might access it
but you can also take it down to the
person level and so there's this notion
of people being in the graph empowering
data power users at lifts surfacing as
potentially institutionalized sources or
repositories themself of personal
information as to how that that column
or that data set might be used is this
particularly powerful and you find
itself people discovering each other
across the organization based on this
feature very much so yeah I think this
was one realization we learned was
that's very important to have people in
the graph and also I will give credit to
Airbnb here
they were also putting people in their
graph and that triggered an idea for us
too and it is definitely very useful so
if I if I'm joining your team Pete I'm
like coming in and saying like Oh what
what data sets and what analysis does
Pete usually do right so I can just go
to Pete's page and figure out what
tables or dashboards you've bookmarked
what tables are dashboards you're most
commonly query and and this information
is very useful as new team members are
onboarding to existing teams it's almost
like I remember what every time I'm
joined a new organization I want to
always look at my peers as Google Groups
or mailing list they've joined just so
I'm not missing out on any information
and I feel the exact same way about this
data world like I want to see my my team
leaves or my peers is commonly used data
set to commonly use dashboards to
actually onboard to the team really
quickly super powerful well if you had
asked me in three months ago whether
this problem would be useful startups
were a big companies I would have
thought oh this is a big company thing
this is a big company problem lots of
data fragmented sources growing team you
don't know who all the players are but
now in this sort of
semi-permanent work from home or at
least that we're facing now it seems
like even medium-sized teams or smaller
teams would benefit from tools like like
half Munson because you can discover a
lot more intuitively about the system
about the data and about the key players
then you would be since you know lots of
teams onboarding and orientation schemes
sitting next to each other and sharing
coffees and having conversations about
the window
absolutely yeah I think historically
I've found that there needs to be a
certain amount of for lack of better
word chaos in the company for for
something like this to make sense than
this chaos can come from like not
everybody understanding like the data
that's being produced at a really fast
pace or people having a different
understanding of their data sets or
people join the company really fast so a
fast growing company you don't have you
don't want to rely on tribal knowledge
of certain people cuz that box the
company down right and so I think those
if you have any of those problems
something like this makes sense now as I
was saying Amazon can integrate a lot of
metadata and each of these metadata
provides incremental value to you so the
first one is the the information schema
style metadata and the second one is the
query locks and then there were a whole
bunch of other ones and you would find
that as her organization grows that more
and more metadata resources would become
more and more relevant to you but to
start off you could start off something
really simple with just one or two kinds
of metadata and power that through for a
small organization and then as time goes
on you can add on these additional data
integration points for metadata so let's
go to a couple more questions
Ramakrishna is asking about technical
metadata versus business metadata would
you say that Amundsen serves tech folks
more than business folks or how do you
sort of see the use decayed split across
who is best served by Amundsen currently
yeah that's a great question around
question
so maybe I'll take the business folks
because I think people may mean
different things on business folks so
I'm gonna break
that term down into roles perhaps so I
would talk about three roles data
engineer no doubt that's a technical
role data scientist or analyst don't
know where that fit I think different
people put in a different category and
the third one is maybe an operator right
so this is your marketing ops person or
finance ops person right pretty clearly
business person okay so I want to say
the first version of famine s'en is
focused on the data engineer and the
data scientist yeah
relatively technical people and the
metadata is still contains it's actually
business-related
right so if I have a column called ETA
right i if you've taken Alif right you
know I show you ETA like 15 times right
when you're like opening up your app
like oh the driver is like three minutes
away and then as you go through the
funnel of requesting the right like I
show you ETA different times and when
you actually have clicked request right
there's the real ETA right so if a
column is called ETA you still had to
understand what this ETA means but
perhaps still a fairly technical
definition so the first version of
famine focused on data sets and these
technical producers and consumers of
data what we are doing with Amundsen now
especially with dashboards is that we
are going into a world where a business
user who usually operates in the world
of dashboards right because if they need
to get a new dashboard they will work
with the data engineering team or the
data science team to get that dashboard
but they want to see what dashboards are
out there who is using this dashboard
can I use that too right and that
especially with the dashboard world is a
new for a and I would say that in our
journey of solving the technical people
problem we are fairly far along but we
were just beginning to think about the
journey for solving it for the more
business folk and what about sort of
related to that but going back to the
technical side what about machine
learning use cases are you tracking
feature stores are you tracking machine
learning metadata are you tracking any
kinds of labeling
tagging of data how hot is Addison
currently relate to any machine learning
activity I left is that a specific
integration point yeah that's another
great question that is a work in
progress we have historical abandoned
data set focused and now are exploring
what it means for features what we do
store today is the offline features
because they happen to be stored in the
same data store that we store the
analytical data in so by virtue of that
you get them however a big problem in
the ml world is linking the online and
the offline features and we don't have
that ability today it's something as we
invest more in feature discovery we
would we would explore another thing to
keep in mind here is model discovery so
like just like we went from tables to
dashboard the equivalent in the ml
worldís features two models and you may
also depends on organizational
preferences you may be in a world in
which you actually don't want people to
discover features but you want people to
actually look at the existing models and
reuse features that already exist right
and so I think we are still working on
figuring that part out and it's a work
in progress an ongoing basis and what
about streaming systems would you have a
similar answer for streaming systems is
that kind of work in progress too are
there other specific considerations just
for general data streaming overall yeah
that comes up quite often which is
indexing things like streams or kafka
topics and the schemas associated with
them
we already index schemas that go
downstream and create a table so
oftentimes you have two data flowing
through Kafka then ultimately lands in a
table and hive or something like that
and we index that so you can actually
see the comments that were associated
upstream and trickle them down all the
way to the pipeline in cases where the
Kafka topic is just used for a flink job
of spark streaming job or something like
that we don't we don't cater to that use
case I it's mostly been because not
because it's not important but the the
amount of data and the amount of options
you have in an analytical data store
like hive or pressed or some things like
that
is like a ten or a hundred times more
than the number of topics you may have
with Kafka right so we we anticipate
we'll get to that problem but the
dataset static data set badge compute
problem was actually much more timely to
solve given the amount of data that
existed in that space well I see we're
getting great interaction from the
audience a bunch of people sign it off
and said they definitely had data
discovery problems so mark let's follow
that up with a follow-up question for
those folks that would say you have
currently or in the past data discovery
problems we're wondering what state
you're at now are you about the sort of
do-nothings to age and just recognizing
you have a problem or you got the
exploring stage ray exploring solutions
or are you a perhaps have you found a
solution suppose would be the three
potential answers you're at the
beginning you're exploring or you've
actually found a solution so you can
sound off in the chat and we'll continue
to take questions from the audience as
well
so mark CJ is asking about data quality
how is that measured and forced and I'm
a few questions sort of surrounding this
as well and sort of what the edges of
the Amundsen purview are but do you want
to talk about data quality for a second
first and hi I'm it's my views there yes
the way I think about data quality is
actually unrelated to Amundsen from the
first glance right so the idea is that
different data sets require different
quality quality metrics and they're
based on the consumption patterns and
the production patterns of these data
sets right so v or data set and I I
agree with the owner that this
particular as a consumer I agree with
the owner this particular field should
never be now right or this particular
this data set should always have Rho
count between a certain standard D like
three standard deviations of the last
two weeks running count right we agree
on this that's my definition of a data
quality contract and then I either miss
or or meet that contract right
and what people care about is how in the
context of data discovery is like how
often do you meet that contract and can
I trust it right so the way I see this
is like there's a separate system for
having data quality contracts and
meeting them and then that system ingest
the metadata into Amazon which is then
used to power as an additional metadata
single power what data sets are high
quality in the discovery and the
curation experience of that so now I
said some amundsen is just a catalog of
the metrics video metrics as they exist
it's a it's a sort of truths regarding
this metadata but it's not in and of
itself enforcing quality contracts or
perhaps sending alerts when data goes
bad or missing it's just sort of
exploratory tool to be able to discover
those things and the other quality
system could be adjacent to that that's
right yeah and they share the same
metadata so I think the other point to
note here is that Amundsen has four
pieces in the architecture there's a
front-end application there's that
that's what most people see in the blog
posts and presentations there's the
graph database which we've talked a bit
about there's an elastic search cluster
with a whole bunch of search magic now
the fourth pieces of data builder system
which is either a crawler where you can
pull metadata in or a push push model
where someone can push metadata this the
graph that I was talking about the data
map or the data graph that graph is
shared between the data quality system
and the data discovery system so think
of it as this layer of metadata that's
powering multiple applications and the
first application is just data discovery
which is Amazon but the graph underneath
has shared with their data quality
system so they can interoperate on the
same graph the vision for just the data
discovery app is this think of it like a
like Facebook for your data exploration
right so you have your data set if
there's an ongoing incident happening it
shows you the metadata
if there is a failed data quality check
it shows you the metadata it shows any
recent changes they met that may have
happened on this data set shows a feed
off like information or contract on the
data set and how often they are being
met who else is using this data set all
this work and so you go to this place to
actually stay on top of what's happening
with your data set and what new things
are created in the work that you are
doing but I think the key point here is
that the underlying metadata graph is
shared that powers multiple application
yeah so in that scenario I'm thinking of
a datum lineage Wow I'm thinking of a
data monitoring app right was thinking
of a date equality and those could all
be different and user applications built
against a common meta story I think
that's fast
yeah and that was one surprised learning
for me was to put was to work with the
Amundsen team and left and put out this
open source project but then half-square
taken in a completely different
direction right which is relying on the
same metadata and parts of the data
discovery application but they modify
the application where you are now
tagging various columns as PII or not
and then hitting the same graph data
gates in the background programmatically
to then allow or deny access to people
who are who are trying to access a
certain DSM and is this is the security
use case that you mentioned previously
beginning the show yeah that's the same
yeah so let's let's stick with the graph
for a bit and sort of the the data
crawler part of the system since we have
another follow-up question from CJ he's
asking if there's of ontology that guy's
metadata acquisition
I'm seized you the way I'm taking this
question please shine back in on Chad if
this is not the way you wanted to go was
that maybe a glossary of business terms
that are guiding how we capture metadata
we currently this is a commonly asked
request for us but we currently don't
have a pattern for this our current
solution around ontology it's that maybe
give you a concrete example so
oftentimes in organizations you have
different ways to refer to the same
logical thing right and so like an ETA
may also be called an ETD I'm just
making this up by the way now you know
totally made-up example or a passenger
may be called the PAC's or a passenger
or a writer you know and so you have to
link all these terms together to the
same sort of definition and what we do
is currently in tables we we use tags in
order to get around that so we would say
you know if the table name is called
Ryder we were tagging with packs and
passenger so when someone searches for
any of those terms it pushes you towards
the writer table and on a related topic
mark what are the current data sources
that you support I assume there's a lot
of work in creating the the adjustors
although I believe you've you've used
some open source in the backend on data
crawler as well is that really used
Goblin yeah that's where we use Goblin
and it was a goblin inspired in
architecture based on some of the
engineers and the team had worked in
London in the past and you may have seen
talks from them gin and Taos pacifically
had worked at LinkedIn and and they were
pretty inspired by that architecture so
it uses a goblin inspired architecture
in the back and then in the in terms of
extractors that are super broad and I
don't know if I I can give an exhaustive
list but any any database connector
that's pretty commonly used it's
connected so you can connect to things
like hive medicine
which powers any Big Data style database
like hive and presto and Impala but we
also have connectors to snowflake
bigquery druid Cassandra my sequel
Athena Amazon glue and then we also have
a generic sequel connector based on
alchemy
which you can use to connect to any
database that I may not have named right
now so that list is fairly broad in
terms of dashboard connections we
connect currently to mode but that a lot
of organizations in the months an open
source community have expressed
extending that to connect to tableau or
looker in the in the HR sort of people
space we connect to a system that we
have an API to an internal system that's
our HR database but that API can be
extended to work with workday pretty
easily and those are and we have a
pretty heavy integration with the
airflow for our ETL and dag information
so those are some of the salient
connectors we have so you're suppose to
come up a couple times
are there other tools in the data
ecosystem that you commonly sort of see
being implemented surrounding I mean
Singh I guess the patent question from
this show is what what other tools do
you play nicely with yeah I think air
flow for a Munson is used in two ways
one is to actually capture metadata so
data engineers for example could see how
their DAGs and their tables are related
it also helps us in the future get
metadata like this data set just got
delivered or this data set is running
late and missing the SLA things of that
nature which are super useful to the
data scientists and analysts here
Amundson also has ETL jobs in the
background for generating stats for
capturing this metadata and building the
search index and all of those in the
back also use air flow in terms of other
tools in the ecosystem that Amundson
plays nicely with I would say that the
graph oh yeah one point I should
the graph database is actually
replaceable right so all of these four
pieces I was talking about in the
architecture are micro-services so you
can actually take one out and keep the
other three around and so one thing that
we see commonly is that people will take
the graph database out and plug in their
own existing solution for metadata
capturing a common existing solution for
organizations have been around for a
while are things like Apache Atlas and
this goes back to the other part of the
question you were asking earlier is like
compared to commercial as well opens
open source solutions so maybe this is a
good segue into that but you can take if
your organization already has existing
investment in Atlas you keep the other
three parts of a months and around and
you replace a graph store with Atlas and
that's exactly what ing has done right
ing has a lot of organizational buy-in
and work that's gone into Atlas over the
last five ten years and then they they
are they're using a Munson and they're
replacing it the graph database with
Atlas so we see a good chunk of that as
well there is one company in the
community I'm not sure if I'm allowed to
share but they are replacing the rap
database with the Amazon version off the
graph I think it's called Neptune or
tight end or something like that
and so there are and that one is not
they will still use the model that
Amundsen provides it was just that they
wanted to choose a different underlying
storage instead of the the current free
edition of neo4j that come on scene
comes with now obviously some teams have
investments in infrastructure and other
kinds of I'm guess stores that might be
more meaningful for them just important
in this capacity so so mark I want to
switch gears a little bit because um and
we didn't talk about this previously but
you're one of these sort of unique
crosses between an engineer and a
product manager and to become apparent
to me just in chatting with you about
Amundsen the use cases some of this
plug-in architecture some of the
strategic sense that you have around
where this project could go you possess
this sort of split brain beach
the implementation of the engineer but
the strategy or the product manager do
you have any thoughts on like first of
all is that a thing did I did I
articulate that correctly and secondly
it's always been one of my beliefs that
open-source projects need project
managers or they need some vision of
where the project is going and sometimes
that's naturally embodied in the leader
of the project but sometimes a leader of
the project is very much an engineer and
doesn't sort of have that ability or
that interest in communicating a
cohesive roadmap to the community can we
talk about that for a second do you have
any man that's a that's a great point I
actually will start off by saying that I
am I'm mostly a product manager I used
to be an engineer and what I am saying
here is actually learning from a huge
team of a small team of really capable
engineers right so there there are team
members Taj and Tamika daniel sheng gu a
leg-up and who are and then many more
that have worked at various times in the
project and then gone off to do other
things and so what I'm sharing is simply
a curation of information sometimes and
learnings from them and by no means do I
represent like the single voice and
voice in the project in terms of open
source communities yeah I think I have
seen communities function well where
there is one organization really moving
the Charter off the project and usually
within that one organization you have
one or two people who are owners off
that project that bring they bring the
passion and the and the resilience to
move this project forward great for them
it's more than just a job it is like
solving this problem I'm super excited
about it and I want to help others solve
the same problem too right and I just
probably like there's vision in that
goal yeah absolutely and I know working
with the Amundson team at lift that I
share that same sentiment with racing
person in the team right and it just so
happens that I have perhaps more
interest in coming to a podcast but I
think that the vision is shared between
the team and we continue to iterate on
it together
so I I definitely by no means would say
that I'm the engineering architect I
think the team is the engineering
architect of the project and I have been
more off the person who is spending a
lot of time understanding the users
workflows and sort of working with the
team to figure out creative solutions to
solve those problems that's great so
here's another question from wrongly and
he's asking his amundsen specifically
integrated with DBT oh great question
this comes up every once in a while and
we do know that we have some shared
users and DBT provides information like
lineage that can be captured in the
Amundson graph but I don't know at the
top of my mind about that
my mind what that current status is and
how those users that use Amundsen and
DBT are using them together I think that
would be a great data point where you
could get integration from tool like DBT
into the metadata graph and have a
discovery and Trust experience on the
other side of that that would be a great
place for us to explore in something
where someplace this is a place where
contributions are greatly welcomed
because in my day-to-day work
we don't use DBT nm and Sand directly so
really relying on others to actually
educate us and take the project under
direction that could serve your use case
yeah suffice to say that DBT could act
on any data that happens and also acts
on but as he's tracking the the
transformations inside the Amundsen
graph that were affected by DBT that
would could potentially be a fun
integration on that note our next guest
on the show will be drew from Fishman
Island analytics to talk about DBT so
thanks from Peter for that question DBT
is hugely popular our communities and we
we know that and we're great supporters
of each other Fishtown of data Council
and so drew will the next guest
- stay tuned for that yeah phenomenal
absolutely and you might be listening so
so mark like one of the main things sort
of has me wrap up because as you know
our goal is to keep these tracks well
under an hour sometimes we're closer to
an hour and some of em for nought but we
don't want to be people we don't want
people to be married to their zoom for
too long even though it's sort of a work
from home world right now
one of the things that you're looking
for from the community and how can the
data counsel community help with
amundsen yeah absolutely
Amonson as you know is an open source
project we have a community about 600
individuals right now from various
different companies I would imagine
probably around 100 companies 20 of them
use amundsen heavily contribute to the
project we think this is a problem
bigger than just 20 companies right and
we want you if you have this problem try
this project out check out the github
link join the slack channel community is
super helpful in helping each other out
as your onboarding or as you're
contributing features and use it for
your use case right I have seen
communities take project in the past in
a slightly different direction than the
originator organization hadn't thought
about and that's happened to a Munson as
well and I think it would be great to
see what you see this project as and
share your ideas and direction and where
this could help with integrations or
more metadata or direction so like come
contribute learn share insight share
feedback would love for you to be a part
of the community great and we'll be
posting those links in the chat window
in the show notes so that you can check
out the Henderson and their slack
community as well so mark as we wrap up
tell me something that you're most proud
of about Evanston besides perhaps just
its usage and the adoption and scene is
there something that that was
technically challenging or hard or
interesting that
particularly satisfied of the solution
that you and the team could created yeah
I I think the team spent a lot of time
one thing that the team did was they
actually did a quick hackathon off the
project so actually first version of
Amundson was built in two weeks and it
was the super scrappiest craziest like
embarrassingly short version of Amundsen
just to see where there are technical
roadblocks or places that we wanted to
learn from and quickly and that team did
a fantastic job of that and I think that
was a great learning for me is like when
you have a lot of ambiguity in the
future of the technical direction like
this can really help with that and then
obviously we threw that version away and
rebuilt the whole thing from scratch but
we knew what we were doing so and I
think the team also was super thoughtful
in building an extensible graph model
that could accommodate various different
kinds of metadata as we went on right
and making sure that that metadata was
grabbable and portable by Amundsen the
data discovery app which is the first
app that took this metadata but also
usable by other applications in a
programmatic manner which i think is one
of the key differentiators of Amundsen
that you can't you don't have to use
this metadata through a UI app but you
could argument and use it to other means
that's great well mark thanks for coming
on the show and the great to talk to you
about Amundsen we're looking forward to
seeing more updates and feel free to
keep the community posted where can
folks find you is Twitter best or in the
Amundsen slack or what other channels
are in twitter is great Amundsen slack
channel is awesome use either of those
and we look forward to talking to you
more
well thanks mark I look forward to
seeing in the community soon